our last topic in this chapter
is the pseudo inverse of a matrix
so we're going to start with a
connection between a gram matrix
and the matrix itself so it's this if
you have a matrix a
it has linearly independent columns if
and only if its gram matrix
is invertible okay so
what does it mean to say it has linearly
independent columns it basically says
that if ax
equals zero that implies that x equals
zero
right because this simply says that
there's a linear combination
of the coefficients oh sorry there's a
linear combination of the columns of a
with coefficients given by x i
is zero and linear independence says the
only way to do that is when all the
coefficients are zero and that's what
this is
so this is what we're this is what this
is what it means uh for the columns of a
to be linearly independent okay
now to show this what we're going to
show is that ax is zero
uh if and only if a transpose x a a
transpose a
x is zero now these are different sizes
right if a is m by
n that is an m uh that's that
that has size m this has size n uh in
this case
because that's an n times n uh system
uh matrix and then that's a this is a
and then the zero on the right hand side
is also size n okay
so let's do this so first of all suppose
ax
equals 0. and if you like that means
that there's a linear combination of the
columns of a
which is 0. then we're going to
we're going to show that basically the
same if i multiply by a transpose ax i
get 0. so let's see
so a transpose a x i'm going to
reassociate that as a transpose
times ax ah but ax is 0. so this is a
transpose 0
and that's 0. okay and so what this
tells you is
if that says that if ax equals 0 then a
transpose a
x equals 0. okay now conversely
suppose a transpose a x equals 0.
then what we're going to write is i'm
going to take this thing
which is an n vector and i'm going to
multiply on the left by x
x transpose and i'm going to get 0 is
well x transpose times 0 is 0. so
i get 0. but i'm going to reassociate
this quadruple product
in the following way i'm going to
rewrite that as first i'm going to write
it as
x transpose a transpose a
x and then i'm going to re-uh i'm going
to reassociate it this way
and then x transpose a transpose i will
recognize
as ax quantity transpose
okay ah but wait a minute
this is the transpose of a vector inner
product with itself or sorry the
times itself right and that's the norm
squared
so this says that zero is the norm
of ax well the only way you can have a
norm or norm squared be zero is if the
the
argument itself is zero so that says ax
equals zero
and so what this does is it tells us uh
it establishes that a has linearly
independent columns if it only if a
transpose a
is is invertible okay so so that's a
connection between
a matrix and the and the gram and its
associated gram matrix
okay and now we can say we can tell you
what the pseudo inverse of a tall matrix
is
i should say that this is pretty
standard mathematical notation like
everybody knows what the sugo what a
pseudo-inverse is
there's some other names for it it's
also called i think the more penrose
inverse
that's especially if you if you come
from the uk
they were british mathematicians um
and it's probably got some other names
as well um
oh and it's notation is this it's a
superscript with a dagger
and and so in fact in in informal speech
you might say a dagger
so that's what it is okay and here's
what it is and you know these things get
very complicated to parse but you really
got to be on your toes to make sure
everything's cool
it's a transpose a quantity inverse a
transpose
okay so um let's quick let's do a quick
syntax
check let's make a is m by n
and let's just let's just check that the
dimensions make sense
okay so a transpose is an
n by m matrix now
let's see let's look at a transpose a
that's the gram matrix by the way so a
transpose a
a is m by n a transpose
is n by m and so the result a transpose
a
is n by n that's the gram matrix it's n
by n
and so this is now the inverse of an n
by n matrix is an n by n matrix so this
is n
by n and sure enough we're cool because
we're multiplying two matrices and
the uh the the dimension in the middle
is equal
okay so it's in so the whole thing a
dagger is an n
by m matrix so a dagger
kind of looks like the transpose uh
right because it's
it it has the it has the transposed
dimensions
um okay and it's equal to this now so
far
that means nothing to you and in fact
it's not even going to make it mean a
whole lot to you
now actually in the next section of the
course it's going to make all
it's actually going to mean a lot to you
we'll get to that okay
now first thing to note about a dagger
or a pseudo inverse
is that it is a left inverse of a
so let's just check um eight that means
if i multiply it on the left
um if i multiply a on the left by a
dagger so if i do that i just plug this
stuff in
and i reassociate this as a transpose a
inverse times a transpose a but a matrix
any matrix times its inverse on the left
is the identity so
look at that so we now have a left
inverse by the way
we have now shown something that uh
i mentioned a few lectures ago but did
not
actually uh derive and that
is that if a matrix has independent
columns
then it has a pseudo inverse and now we
can be very explicit
it's like here's by the way it can have
it will have multiple pseudo inverses
if it's tall but the point is it has at
least a pseudo inverse and in fact
here's a simple formula for it it's a
transpose a inverse a transpose
um so so that's that's now established
that was something left open from a
couple lectures ago um
now there's some uh by the way
it's very easy to get into trouble with
these kinds of equations right like
like like that um it's just too easy to
just look at it not be present
or not be thinking about what it means
and all of a sudden you're in big big
trouble
and to to do that i'm going to work out
we're going to see
what the pseudo inverse is when a is
square so if a is square
then a dagger is equal to a transpose a
in parentheses quantity inverse times a
transpose now
because a is squared i'm gonna i can
actually say that a transpose a is the
product of two square matrices
inverse that's the inver that's the
product of the inverses in reverse order
so this is a inverse times a transpose
inverse that's slang for a transpose
inverse is a
minus t or something like that and then
multiplied by a
transpose now this is the identity
and it goes away so you get a inverse so
we can think of the pseudo inverse
as a as a generalization of an inverse
to the case when a matrix a is
tall let's say oh and i should say as
in linearly independent columns then
that's that's what the pseudo inverse is
and indeed it's a left inverse of that
so okay
so that that is the later we're going to
find out that's actually much more
special than just
merely a left inverse it's got some very
special properties but for now we'll
just
uh leave it this way that's what the
pseudo inverse
is um i should also say that you know
all
languages for manipulating uh matrices
all packages and languages will indeed
have
some function that carries out the
pseudo inverse
okay now we also have the pseudo inverse
of a wide matrix so if a is wide
then um a a transpose that is by the way
the gram matrix of a transpose
that's invertible and the pseudo inverse
is then defined
this way it's a transpose times a a
transpose
quantity inverse now again you have to
be so
careful with these things because you
can write down stuff like this
and it's either meaningless or wrong
that's extremely you have to be very
careful so
this requires a to be wide with linearly
independent rows otherwise
this makes absolutely no sense it's just
like parts of it are just
wrong like things are not invertible all
that kind of stuff okay
now not surprisingly a dagger the the
pseudo inverse of a wide matrix with a
linearly independent rows
is a right inverse the same way a dagger
was a left inverse
when a is tall with linearly independent
columns and you just check that you just
multiply a dagger on the right
and i so i multiply a times
this expression and sure enough i get a
a transpose times a a transpose inverse
and that's the identity so that's it
okay
and once again it too reduces to a
inverse
when a is square okay so
by the way this calculation here
expanding a a transpose
and writing it as a a a transposes a
minus transpose
times a inverse that would be a terrible
crime if a were strictly wide
if a is square and invertible or has you
know linearly independent columns this
is cool
but uh if it were uh if a were y
strictly wide
this would be a terrible crime uh that
the crime there'd be many crimes
committed here
one is that you can't have a non-square
matrix you can't have an inverse of it
that's right so that
you'd be in big trouble right there
now it turns out that the pseudo inverse
we can get it it's
very closely related to the uh to the qr
factorization
let's see how that works um so let's
suppose a has linearly independent
columns and we form a qr comp
a decomposition now because it has
linearly independent columns
gram-schmidt if we use that to calculate
qr is going to succeed and that means
we're going to end up with a matrix q
the same size as a
it and it's going to its column's going
to be orthonormal and r is
upper triangular it's upper triangular
and it's um
with positive entries on the diagonal
okay now
let's work out what is a transpose a
well a is qr so i just go qr
par n transpose qr and now i use the
fact that the product
the transpose of the product is the
transpo is the product of the transpose
is in reverse order
so i get over here uh here i get r
transpose q transpose q
r ah but q transpose q is i
it's the identity because in fact that
that is precisely equivalent to saying
the columns of q
are orthonormal so that's an identity in
the middle it goes away and i end up
with r transpose r
okay interesting now let's take a dagger
a dagger is a transpose a quantity
inverse a transpose
but we just worked out a transpose a is
r transpose r
and so this is r transpose r inverse q r
now
a is c can be tall
so i certainly cannot expand things and
write a inverse
but r is square and invertible so this
thing i can for sure use the rule that
says that
r transpose times our quantity inverse
is the inverse of r times the inverse of
r transpose and so i get this
um oh and then this is q r quantity
transpose
that's the same as the tren the product
of the transpose is in reverse order
and so this is this is r transpose q
transpose so i get there
and what happens is in the next formula
i have an r transpose inverse and r
transpose that line up next to each
other
they annihilate each other the product
is the identity and that
just goes away and i get r inverse q
transpose
um okay uh
so uh so that's this is a very cool
formula it's just r inverse times q
transpose
that's the formula for the pseudo
inverse of a of a
tall uh matrix right linearly
independent columns
or call or square that doesn't matter um
okay now that means i can actually
calculate the pseudo inverse because i
could
just do this to do that i'm going to i'm
going to calculate a dagger
times e i that's going to give me the i
column
of a dagger and to do that i'll simply
write it as
r inverse times q transpose e i
okay so now i see what we do we do a qr
factorization
you do a qr factorization on a
then you take the columns of q transpose
that's these things and for each of
those
you do a back substitution and this will
give you uh
the a dagger right and it will give you
uh it'll give you this because you'll
compute it column by column so
that's that's how that okay so that
um that is the qr factorization
um i uh i should say this this finishes
a section of the an entire section of
the course
um we've seen vectors matrices
uh the concept of inverses and solving
linear equations
and we even know how to do it uh
when i should say various matrices have
linearly independent columns or are
invertible if it's square
so that's where we are so far so you
know some you know some things and you
can do some useful things
i should say that the course is about to
get much more useful
in the next section when we talk not
about solving equations
but about solving equations
approximately
and that's going to be coming up as the
next section
of the course